ciao a tutti i temi che voglio trattare
oggi raggiunge proporzioni tragiche per
la vita di ognuno di noi
in particolare per la mia sento questa
sincero che con l'intelligenza l'arguzia
l'astuzia che mi hanno tramandato i
genitori riesco a fatica ad allacciarmi
le scarpe che consente alla xvi subito
curato dal man city tutto di carlos
hanno detto basta ad allacciarsi le
scarpe a secco di renderlo pubblico
sante dispiace gli incubi locali non
affrontate sputtani a te se va beh a
parte quello vi è mai capitato una cosa
simile
pronto e mi stai bene dubbio bene mai
capito di sorsi cazzata è certo e
continuo pure aq meglio impiegare la
mitica ha mai capito che solo no pronto
è guglielmo ciao a te noceto madre
no non c'è a casola mannaggia non
riescono a beccarla erano solo sheva
comunque da quanto non a centro voce
quanto tempo davvero a ricordi che
ricordi da per i ricordi nascosto nomi e
risate
mamma mia mamma mia come dimenticare
anche mia miei specie io non sono
proprio capace non riesco a fingere una
conoscenza del soggetto o ancora peggio
quando ti fa nel trabocchetto perché
sono più intelligenti di te pronto
ciao ciao problemi con lui
se sì poi lombardo è l'uni non ho mai
inteso come va in generale ecco
presenti che ti passo verso le 23
ok che non ho assorbito
a quel punto dopo aver passato la
cornetta e mezza casa di via
destinatario della chiamata
vergognandosi come un ladro
e poi ci sono i momenti peggiori quando
sei di persona e non ti ricordi nome
della persona che ti è stata appena
presentata
lei calpurnia e la mia ragazza ei miseri
calpurnio il k devo detto iniziava
cesare rossi è tranquilla ma come
quest'anno disposto in macchina allora
siamo io te giorgio marco e passiamo io
te giorgio man o di un asse che non me
lo ricordo bene arrivano di noi
chiediamo ragazze bene da lui poi fai
prego dimmi cosa fare e medicina si può
aggiustare
certo se microcar coordinamento mista
che la prima volta mi inviterete come
cosa atto
esatto si presenta così perché il
piacere di vederti è infatti se assume
così lontani da ci siamo conosciuti sarà
davvero a guadagni luce km galassi caos
mivar di distanza si va beh meglio
finirla qui ti ringrazio mark per avere
dato tu la risposta che se no avrei dato
io e ovviamente no la graffetta non
faceva male perché avevo usato un trucco
segreto per potermi per potermi evitare
il dolore sinceramente non ho più
pallida idea di cosa siano questi truzzi
emu cose mani però è sempre bello dare
fiato alle trombe non trovi non lo so un
cleaver tempo per il ballo del piero
come stai